は：お前らに.....
は：話さなきゃいけないことが有るんだ
た：どーしたんだよ
ま：はじめさん、なんですか？
は：最近さぁ....
は：俺、寝れない日多くてさ
は：なんでか、分かんないんだよ
は：ナンデカワカンナインダヨ!!!
は：でも寝れなくて
は：寝不足で、俺どうしたら良いか分かんなくて
は：もうアレを飲むしか、ねぇんだよ
ま：はじめさん？
た：はじめん！
ま：はじめさん、何すかコレ
た：はじめ何だよコレ!!
は：見りゃ分かんだろ
は： 超ぐっすり爆睡サプリだよ！！
ま&た：超ぐっすり爆睡サプリ！？？
は：そうだよ
は：もう、コレに頼るしか無いんだよ
は：寝れないんだよ、怖くて
は：これだけ飲めば寝れるよな？
は：そうだろ？
は：これだけ飲めば、ぐっすり寝れるよな！！？
た：やめろ！はじめ！！
は：やめろよ、お前ら！！！
は：やめろよ ．．．！
た：やめるんだ！！
は：ダメだ！！
ま：はじめ！
は：やめろよ！！
ま：やめな！
は：やるしか無いんだよ！俺はもう！！
は：行かせてくれ、俺を！！
は：駄目だぁ！！
は：やるしか無いんだよ、もう俺には！！！
た：やめろよ！
ま：やめろって！
た；待つんだ
た：待つんだ、はじめん
ま：何んだよ．．．
た：待つんだ．．．
ま；駄目だって！
た：いやっ！無理だ、 はじめん
ま：駄目だよ！！
た：やめろ！やめろ！
は：やめろよぉぉお！！！
は：俺はもう飲むしか、ねぇんだよ！
は：もう止めれねえからな．．．
ぅゔ！！
ま&た：はじめ、どうした！！？はじめ！！はじめさん！！
ま&た：しっかりしろ！はじめさん！！はじめん！！
た：はじめーーーーー！！！！
ま&た：ハッジメーーン！！！
は：あれ？
？：ん？
は：誰だ、お前ら！！
？：起きたー！起きた！よぉし！！起きた
？：待ってたぞ！！
た：はじめん、俺だよ！たくみだよ！！
ま：もう心配したんだよ、はじめさーん
はs：ジジィやないかい
三人：ハハハハハｗｗｗｗ
wwww
♪エンディング♪
は：ジジィやないかい
ま&た：ハハハ．．．ｗｗｗｗｗ
ｗｗｗ